[Music]
you know when I talk about the symbolic
victories black men in the white house
precious black family in the white house
I mean legacy white supremacy in America
you can't help but celebrate I've told
it but I was gonna breakdance which I
did but only in the afternoon the next
one I woke up made you critic how your
policies make the porn working people
you have to breakdance in terms of that
breakthrough cuz racism is real and it's
it has an ugly and vicious history in
the country so for him to be in the
White House is quite significant
symbolically at the level of substance
what kind of policies you're gonna bail
out investment bankers if you're going
to have public options negotiable and
make deals with greedy drug companies
and pharmaceutical companies before you
and that before you even have a
substantive debate on on health care
then it's clear you're not tilting
toward the point working classes you're
tilting toward the well-to-do and I'm
afraid sometimes in my dear brother
Brock Obama's to mesmerize not just
about Wall Street he's mesmerized by
braininess of those who are on intimate
terms with Wall Street
my dear brother Larry Summers brilliant
brainy tied into a Wall Street
Weltanschauung a Wall Street worldview
cronies best friends comrades tied into
hedge fund communities and so forth so
that we can always applaud his
brilliance but brilliance and braininess
need to be tied to a framework that put
poor and working people at the center
this is why they can celebrate
recessions over recovery set in for who
Wall Street yes everyday people
escalating unemployment underemployment
much of which they don't even count as
you know you think but that's what you
have when you have a neoliberal
framework jobs are a second thought
weren't working people are third thought
poor people not even on your radar
screen so we need to have voices out
there that are very honest and candid
about those persons who have been
thoroughly left behind during the age of
Reagan and of course having a longer
history in terms of issues of race and
class and Empire and gender and my gay
brothers unless
sisters very important